these small planes are rescuing children
in a remote part of Northern Brazil
the indigenous Yanomami people say they
have been asking for help for the last
four years
it's finally arrived but many have
suffered
we see that there are serious cases they
are indigenous merely children with
malnutrition pneumonia dehydration they
are usually children in a serious
condition the Amazon's Yanomami
population live in an area of fertile
land but mining has destroyed the
habitat of animals they hunt and it's
had devastating consequences for them
hospitals are now filled with
malnourished children
some now in intensive care
facilities here are basic but there are
no hospitals in their remote Villages
becomes what we have been for four years
without Health assistance in the
communities 120 communities are fighting
for life more than 20 000 gold miners in
the Yanomami indigenous land with guns
are intimidating communities communities
are living with fear
the military have been air dropping food
and medical supplies
Brazil's new president Luis inacio Lula
de Silva has blamed his predecessor gyro
boltonaro and has pledged to help
we will take very seriously the task of
ending illegal gold mining and even if
it's in an authorized area for research
they can do research without destroying
the water the forest and risking the
lives of people that depend on that
water to survive
but for now yanamami parents are hoping
their children will get better
and they can once again return to their
lands and live freely